Mais qu'est-ce que je veux que je vous dise ?
Enfin, nous, on est ni la droite,
ni la gauche, on est le parti, euh. Des français.
En plus, on est parti de La Défense,
euh. Des intérêts des français. Donc y a des gens, euh.
De la droite qui viennent nous rejoindre.
Et puis y a des gens qui viennent de la gauche aussi,
hein, euh.
Y compris même de la France insumiste parfois.
Hum. Et. Et.
Et. Nous allons accueillir l'ensemble de ces personnes,
parce que, encore 1 fois,
nous sommes 1 Rassemblement National,
c'est notre nom,
c'est pas notre nom par hasard,
c'est notre nom parce que c'est notre
philosophie également.
Maintenant, si vous voulez, la droite,
elle est responsable de sa situation.
La droite, elle n'a plus rien à offrir,
elle n'a plus aucune idée,
elle n'a plus de leader.
Euh. Et. Hum. La moitié de ses idées,
euh. Ce sont les nôtres
et. Et l'autre moitié, sur le plan économique,
ce sont celles euh.
D'Emmanuel Macron.
Donc, euh, euh, je. Je peux comprendre que, euh.
Ils n'arrivent plus, euh. À trouver euh.
Le 1 oreille attentive auprès euh.
De nos concitoyens.
Mais c'est de leur responsabilité.
Et puis, après tout, ils ont été au pouvoir aussi.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait quand ils y étaient ?
Rien. Ils ont déçu comme les autres.
Voilà. Donc, euh. Que les gens, ils quittent.
Mais sommes toutes 1 démarche assez naturelle,
c'est trop mignon.
Nous avons toujours fait campagne de la même manière
Des campagnes de proximité,
des campagnes où nous allons au plus près des gens
pour leur parler
de leur préoccupation
et et accessoirement pour leur expliquer,
euh, ce qui était plus compliqué hier qu'aujourd'hui,
que les décisions qui sont prises
au sein de l'Union européenne les impacte
directement dans leur vie quotidienne. Voilà,
beaucoup de contribuables se rendent compte, euh.
Nous versons des sommes formidable à l'Union européenne,
euh. Et que, euh.
Elle nous en restitue euh. De moins en moins, euh.
Beaucoup de nos compatriotes prennent aussi
conscience que l'Union
européenne est en train de s'attribuer des compétences
au détriment, euh. Des Nations.
C'est vrai pour la diplomatie,
c'est vrai pour l'immigration, c'est vrai pour la santé.
Demain, ce sera peut-être vrai pour La Défense,
euh, ce sera peut-être vrai euh pour euh, la fiscalité,
car
nos adversaires souhaitent mettre en place 1 fiscalité
européenne, c'est l'air des impôts en plus.
Donc nous venons leur dire que la nation
est la structure la plus performante pour assurer leur
sécurité, leur prospérité et défendre leur identité,
que on peut faire 1 Europe des nations, bien sûr,
1 Europe des coopérations, bien sûr,
mais que nous n'entendons pas
abandonner ce qui
relève du pouvoir souverain du peuple
à des fonctionnaires non élus.
Bah, il y a 3 en réalité,
euh. Dossiers qui sont des dossiers, euh.
Absolument essentiels.
Il y a d'abord le dossier du pouvoir d'achat.
Vous savez que, on est sur ce sujet depuis, euh.
De nombreuses années.
Alors vous. Me direz, ça dépend pas vraiment
euh. Des européennes,
mais il va falloir régler le problème de loc 3 de mer
dont je parle depuis.
Euh. Des années et des années et des années.
Je vois que le gouvernement commence à s'y intéresser,
tant mieux euh. Donc, je rappelle à ceux
qui nous écoutent que c'est la raison
principale, en réalité,
de l'augmentation
euh. Des prix euh. Sur l'île.
Nous le disions,
ça a été maintenant confirmé par la euh.
Cours des comptes, euh.
Il faut donc
absolument réformer totalement l'octromère,
ça veut dire
le supprimer et faire financer les communes
et les collectivités
par l'état, comme l'état le fait d'ailleurs
par l'intermédiaire des dotations
globales de fonctionnement
dans l'ensemble du pays.
Y a pas de raison que les réunionnais payent 1 taxe
supplémentaire
pour financer ce que le budget de l'état finance
ailleurs. N° 1 est, le maintenir
uniquement pour les
produits qui rentrent en compétition
directe avec les productions euh. Locales.
Et puis il faut lutter contre la fraude aussi, hum. Et. Et.
Notamment euh.
Les habits de
position dominante dans le domaine de l'alimentaire,
et. Et puis euh. Les et sur profit
dans le domaine euh. Du frette maritime.
Euh, ça aussi, ce sont des propositions
qui ont déjà été portées par le Rassemblement National
et que nous continuerons à défendre,
notamment à l'Assemblée nationale.
Le 2e sujet,
c'est évidemment l'immigration et l'insécurité.
Peut pas dire que la réunion soit totalement préservée
de la montée de l'insécurité, hein ?
Euh. Les. Euh. La délinquance a augmenté 17%,
euh. Euh. L'effet de.
Concernant le trafic de drogue a augmenté de 90%.
Il faut donc se saisir du problème.
Maintenant,
il faut pas attendre d'être dans 1 situation
qui est ingérable
pour euh. Réagir.
Et l'immigration, je vous en ai parlé,
il faut reprendre la maîtrise de nos frontières,
et notamment puisque, euh.
Par ricochet, vous subissez
évidemment les conséquences euh.
De la situation cataclysmique euh. De Mayotte,
euh. Hmm. Agir euh. Avec les Comores,
avec 1 véritable bras de fer,
ce qui n'est pas le cas
pour l'instant, on leur déroule le tapis rouge,
on leur fait des chèques de centaines, de 1.000.000 et.
Et. J'en passe et des meilleurs,
hum. Et. Et puis euh, mettre enfin en place les moyens euh.
Techniques pour pouvoir maîtriser
euh. Notre immigration,
ça passera par 1 référendum.
Nous l'avons proposé au français et.
Et je suis convaincu de la réponse,
euh. Qui sera euh. La l'heure dans ce domaine.
Et puis y a euh. L'agriculture et la pêche
qui sont des sujets essentiels.
Encore 1 fois,
nous sommes
contributeurs net à au budget l'Union européenne.
Je rappelle à ceux qui nous écoutent,
arrêtez de vous laisser dire que l'Union européenne
nous paye euh. Nous donne de l'argent,
nous donne des subvention,
c'est notre argent
qui transitent par l'Union européenne,
mais c'est notre argent et chaque année,
elle garde entre 8 et 10 milliards
de l'argent qu'on lui donne.
Donc il faut.
Augmenter euh. Les subvention pour soutenir
euh, la pêche et l'agriculture.
Il faut arrêter avec le pacte vert, qui encore 1 fois
est 1 folie écologiste
qui est en réalité à multiplier les normes qui pèsent
sur les entrepreneurs,
sur les agriculteurs.
On voit d'ailleurs que c'est 1 des raisons euh. Qui, euh
de. De de la pénurie de logement aussi hein,
à la réunion, hein,
euh, euh. Mille-six-cents logements construits,
quarante-cinq-mille besoins.
Bon, il y a 1 moment donné,
on voit qu'il y a 1 difficulté.
Et tout ça, c'est la conséquence encore 1 fois de la
multiplication
euh des des normes.
Et puis il faut soutenir résolument notre agriculture
et son développement.
Or la politique de l'Union européenne,
c'est 1 petit de la décroissance,
c'est-à-dire, ils veulent que nous en fassions moins,
que nous produisons moins, mais au bénéfice de qui ?
Au bénéfice des pays qu'ils veulent faire entrer
dans l'Union européenne
et qui, eux, vont bénéficier
d'une partie de la Pâques ?
Donc évidemment,
nous serons également en partie privée.
Et moi, je leur propose de coopérer, certes,
mais de conserver les moyens de nous défendre
dans la compétition mondiale.